Islandia a punto de ser miembro de la
otan el parlamento de Turquía aprobó de
forma unánime un proyecto de ley para
permitir que el país nórdico sea parte
de la alianza los 30 países han
respaldado la candidatura
como parlamento de Turquía felicitamos
al estado y al pueblo de Finlandia la
propuesta de ley fue aprobada
en Twitter el presidente de Finlandia
celebró el último visto bueno necesario
Finlandia será un Aliado fuerte y
confiable comprometido con la seguridad
de la alianza celebración a la que se
sumó el secretario general de la otan
esto hará que toda la familia de la otan
sea más fuerte y segura con la
incorporación de Finlandia los países
occidentales consiguen un Aliado en el
norte de Europa en la frontera con Rusia
americans
los estadounidenses los franceses y los
británicos pueden ver el mapa y ver que
es un lugar muy importante cuando se
trata de una especie de elemento
geoestratégico de la otan
elementos
la defensa del Norte se hace mucho más
fácil
tras la invasión de Rusia Ucrania
Finlandia solicitó entrar en la alianza
después de décadas manteniendo una
posición de no alineación los fineses
aprueban el ingreso
Security en primer lugar nos da
seguridad por fin vamos a formar parte
del hemisferio occidental
Finlandia se va a convertir en miembro
de la otan en un tiempo récord Suecia
quiere ser el siguiente Pero todavía
tiene desencuentros con Turquía ankara
acusa esto colmó de no haber sido
suficientemente contundente con grupos
que considera terroristas donde se
incluyen militantes kurdos mientras
desde Hungría dicen que Suecia se burla
de su democracia congelándoles fondos
europeos